Watch this video to master
Ushiro Ukemi.
If you are a beginner, or struggling with\hushiro ukemi this is the video for you.
In aikido, in many cases, we get thrown backwards,\hso first you have to learn how to deal with this\hsituation.
In this video I'm gonna show you how\hto do ushiro ukemi step by step,
and then we are\h\hgonna show how to apply it in actual situations.
\hTo overcome the fear of falling backwards, I recommend you to first try this exercise.
First, just\hsit down put your feet together and grab them.
Bend your back a little\hbit and pull your chin down,
so you can roll back and sit up safely.
It also helps if you keep looking at your belly during this exercise.
The next one is a standard ushiro ukemi exercise\hin aikido,
one knee up and one knee down.
You can\hgrab your knees and we are gonna roll back and sit up.
Usually, I prefer to change side while\hmy feet are in the air
so here from left to right.
If your abs are strong enough you can also\htap the mat.
So when my right knee is up I'm going to use my right arm.
Tap the mat and change side.
The next one is from kneeling\hposition, something like this.
Keep your posture straight.
I'm gonna\hsit down.
Make sure that you don't sit\hon your foot like this because it can be dangerous.
Move your foot away, sit on the mat, roll\hyour back, pull your chin down,
and everything\helse goes just like before.
Straight posture.
As I'm falling backward, I gradually bend my back.
Something like this.
After that you can try\hthis exercise from standing in a hanmi position.
You're going to stand on the line,
relax\hyour knees,
and first kneel down from the back knee,
something like this,
bend your back a\hlittle bit keep watching your belly
and stand up.
Right hanmi to left hanmi position.
In actual techniques, we start the ukemi not from the back leg but from the front one.\h\h
So the next exercise is gonna be something\hlike this.
We're going to step back, kneel down, and ukemi.
Step back, kneel down, and ukemi.
Keep your posture straight,
start to bend your neck, chin down,
and execute the back background safely.
The next exercise is a little bit more advanced.
Make sure that you clear all the previous steps\hbefore trying this one
You can open from\hhanmi position,
or start like this,
with your feet, shoulder\hwidth apart,
i'm gonna bend my knees, stretch a\h\hlittle bit backwards,
when I reach my limit, when\hI start to lose my balance,
I start the ushiro ukemi.
Okay something like this.\h
Stretch, start to reach my limit,
and ushiro ukemi.
For the next exercise you're going to\hneed a partner have your bestie,
and first he's going push me softly, gently.
I want to absorb his energy\hand execute the ushiro ukemi safely.
If you get used to this\hmovement, you can increase the force.
Try to absorb.
Something like this.
Now we are going to show\hyou how to apply this ukemi in actual techniques.
First from sumi otoshi katate dori (one-handed\h
grab).
He's gonna step in and throw me backwards.
OK, other side.\h
Don't start the ukemi on your own, the\htiming is very important.
Don't be early like this.
You have to feel what's going on in the technique.
Keep your connection and start doing\hwhen you actually reach your limit.
Thank you for watching, if you like\hthis video please give it a thumbs up\h\h
and don't forget to subscribe,\hsee you in the next video.